SUNDAY AND THEY HAVE LOTS OF
GREAT CATEGORIES LIKE BEST POP
COLLABORATION WITH VOCALS AND
BEST IMPROVISED JAZZ SOLO.
THAT'S A REAL ONE?
YOU CAN NEVER HAVE ENOUGH
CATEGORIES WHICH IS WHY
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#REJECTEDGRAMMYCATEGORIES.
EXAMPLES OF THESE REJECTED
CATEGORIES WOULD BE BEST NEW
FARTIST, BEST UNSPOKEN
WORD PERFORMANCE, BEST NEW
COUNTRY IN THE EVER CHANGING
MIDDLE EAST.
I AM PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK.
READY, GO.
HORATIO SANZ.
>> BEST GOSPEL ALBUM EVEN THOUGH
GOD DOESN'T EXIST.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS AS WE ARE ALL
DAMNED TO HELL.
JON DALY.
>> THE R. KELLY LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD FOR EMPTIEST
BLADDER PRESENTED BY...
(LAUGHTER)
PRESENTED BY CHUCK BERRY.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: OKAY, GOOD, POINTS.
JULIE KLAUSNER.
>> GAYEST MUSICAL.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: YEAH, THAT WOULD BE--
POINTS!
JON?
>> ALAN THICKE'S RAPIEST SON.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS!
HORATIO.
>> BEST SONG BY GAY FRENCH
ROBOTS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: MERCI, POINTS.
JON.
>> THE BRAVEST BACON BROTHERS
BALLAD.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: SO THEY'RE THE ONLY
BAND IN THAT CATEGORY?
(BUZZER)
>> OUT OF ALL THE BALLADS.
>> Chris: YOU SHUT UP, BUZZER!
I'M NOT DONE!
>> OUT OF ALL OF THE BACON
BROTHER BALLADS, THEIR BRAVEST.
>> Chris: YEAH, OKAY GOOD.
POINTS FOR THAT.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)